yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
with another fallout 4 video now in this
video i'm gonna be showing you guys how
to get the x 0 1 power armor which is
the best power armor in the game so what
you're going to want to do is head to
the custom-house tower which is east of
good neighbor or super east of diamond
city you can see it they are on the map
you don't want to get there and once you
get there you're gonna head west to this
green turquoise building called 35 port
you're going to enter this building it's
a pretty simple building and you're
going to head up the elevator and once
you get to the top of this building
there's going to be a pretty intense
fight so I do recommend doing this in
power armor another thing I will note is
that you should be level 29 or above
before you do this otherwise you will
not get X 0 1 power armor you might be
able to do this at 27 Navy 26 I'm not
sure so I suggest doing this at 29 or
else you will not get the xl1 power
armor I can't stress that enough so once
you get to the roof there's going to be
a legendary sentry bot and an assault
Ron so this is a pretty intense fight as
you can see it's like there's a lot of
stuff going on and again just make sure
you're powerful enough to this I
recommend coming in a suit of power
armor to finish this fight because as I
said it's a pretty tough fight and you
can see I'm Evans in trouble with it so
once you finish this fight once you beat
the salt Ron in the century ba head to
the rooms they spawned in and there's
gonna be a button in each room you're
gonna press the button any trim you have
to press both of them and the door in
the middle of the courtyard will open
and boom there you go a full set of X 0
1 power armor with a fusion course you
can just take that to your base right
away now I do have a set of power armor
on so I'm gonna have to get out of that
to get in this one and I'm gonna have to
come back my current set but I do
recommend using a set of power armor
because the fight is so intense with a
freaking legendary century pop and an
assault Ron yeah that's it this is the
XO one power armor if you do this at too
low of a level you will get a different
set of power armor that isn't the XO one
power armor so make sure you're at 29 or
above it might work for 26 27 28 but i'm
unsure so i would just say wait till
you're 29 then come get this it is a
really good suit of power armor it is
the best highest stat power armor in the
game you can see that my current set of
power armor mighty 60 did have better
stats than it because i was saying only
the only some of the parts on the xl1
better than if that's because my t60 is
modded and this set of X 0 1 power armor
has no ma you can mount this also and it
will be the highest amount of armor
rating in the game with power armors
with this xl1 soup to my knowledge it is
the best it is the best power armor suit
in the game that is confirmed don't
worry so that's basically the video you
can see there i go i have my tea 696 see
my txt is the old one I have my XO 1
power suit I have been using a lot it is
a ton of fun and yeah you guys come up
here beat these enemies and press the
buttons you guys can have your own set
of X 0 1 power armor to always I've
enjoyed this make sure you check out my
channel if you are liking this color for
content since i have posted a lot of it
and i will continue to post a lot of
fallout 4 contents i really love the
game and i really love making videos
about it alright so thank you for
watching and peace out